bonjour et bienvenue dans ce qu'ils mag
nous nous intéressons aujourd'hui au
budget 2022 de saint quentin en yvelines
est notre invité n'est autre que thierry
michel bonjour bonjour joue adam alors
tiré michel vous êtes vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué aux
finances et aux ressources humaines tout
à fait et je vais démarrer direct avec
des chiffres parce que saint quentin en
yvelines dispose d'un budget annuel de
400 millions d'euros ce n'est pas rien
alors ça ça va servir à exercer des
compétences obligatoires qui sont fixées
par la loi et il y a également les
compétences supplémentaires qui lui ont
été confiées par ses douze communes au
total cela représente 49 compétences
différentes alors je vous rassure j'ai
pas toutes les citer mais j'ai envie de
vous demander un petit peu le budget ça
concerne tous finalement sa course à
d'ailleurs d'autres choses parce que
finalement dans le budget on peut le
couper en deux grandes parties on a le
fonctionnement où on va retrouver ses
compétences que vous avez cités on
pourrait parler des sections culturelles
on pourrait parler de la gestion des
espaces verts de tout ce qui est de
l'assainissement et il y en a bien
d'autres donc ça effectivement c'est
dans le quotidien et on a une partie du
budget qui est dédié à l'investissement
là c'est effectivement les gros
chantiers les grands investissements en
travaux sur les communes qui vont être
réalisés chaque année avec des
opérations qui parfois vont être exercés
ciani pour prôner ce qu'on appelle dans
des opérations pluriannuel ou alors des
opérations dites récurrente ou
régulièrement on entretient notre
patrimoine sur des preuves de voirie de
stationnement des espaces verts et
autres alors si on revient sur le budget
de cette année en 2022 à saint quentin
en yvelines dans les grandes lignes un
terry michel ça va se répartir comment
alors le bûcher il est essentiellement
en fonctionnement autour de 240 millions
on on va rebondir les chiffres et le
reste sera sur la pâte investissement on
retrouve des grandes masses comme
toujours alors ses compétences aptes que
nous ne nous portons mais il ya aussi
des accompagnements auprès des communes
à travers ce qu'on appelle des
attributions de compensation un peu
technique mais c'est de l'argent qui est
donné aux communes c'est de la
redistribution fiscalité on a aussi du
personnel parce que il faut pour gérer
toutes ces compétences il faut des
effectifs c'est à peu près 700 agents
qui aujourd'hui travaillent pour saint
quentin et après eux quelques postes par
ci par là sur l'investissement ça va se
décomposer en plusieurs parties
disais tout à l'heure on va voir les
opérations forte on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler et puis le la
gestion quotidienne
50 ans c'est un grand territoire donc il
ya beaucoup de travaux il faut toujours
se développer toujours avoir une action
pour cette attractivité car 50 ans est
un territoire très attractif et bien je
vous propose tout de suite de découvrir
un petit reportage en point chiffres en
images
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
thierry michel pour aborder le budget
2022 de saint quentin en yvelines alors
j'ai envie de vous demander cette année
on sort du coc vide est ce que le budget
était plus difficile à mettre en place
plus difficile oui parce que le contexte
ne nous aident pas on était confronté à
une sortie de crise sanitaire à cette
crise du coc vide qui vient impacter
aujourd'hui ma les entreprises et pour
nous ça fait une baisse de recettes
assez conséquente de 5 millions d'euros
et puis on est confronté à ce retour
d'inflation assez fort qui va venir
impacter nos dépenses donc on a déjà des
postes qui vont augmenter fortement à ce
l'on peut rajouter l'état qui m'a nous
retire un peu de dotation c'est un
million de moins et puis on doit cotiser
à ce qu'on appelle la péréquation c'est
l'accompagnement des communes en
difficulté où on nous demande de cotiser
pour 600 millions de plus donc tous ces
éléments ont fait que c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué et qu'il a fallu être
beaucoup plus vigilant dans la stratégie
qu'on souhaitait porter là je me tourne
autour de nous nous sommes dans l'hyper
centre et vous rappeler que saint
quentin en yvelines et bien c'est le
deuxième pôle économique de l'ouest
parisien avec notamment 145 salariés il
ya aussi dix sept mille entreprises
alors quel rôle joue le budget dans
l'attractivité du territoire abbas et
l'essentiel c'est de l'investissement
s'est effectivement pouvoir permettre à
saint-quentin d'être toujours dans une
dynamique les entreprises mais les
particuliers ans y sont très friands le
vigilant sur comment les communes et 50
ans évolue donc là effectivement on est
sur le parvis quasiment de la gare de
saint-quentin où des travaux vont être
entrepris ce qu'on appelle le projet
d'hyper centre car il ya nécessité de sa
de s'adapter aujourd'hui au contexte
quelque part à une manière de vivre qui
a changé de l'apparition de zones de nos
administrés et puis des personnes qui
travaillent à 50 à khartoum où n'habite
pas forcément 50 a donc vous êtes sur un
endroit stratégique aujourd'hui elle est
douce comme dans tout les douze communes
et joue un rôle essentiel parce que 51
finalement c'est quoi ces douze communes
réunis qui ont effectivement un rôle
très important dans l'activité alors
peut-être plusieurs domaines locale
effectivement et saint quentin et
partenaires accompagnent et communes à
travers différents modes de financement
qui va permettre aux communes de
matières cette activité sur des travaux
plus locaux hop on les colle les écoles
par exemple mais ça c'est une stratégie
très très important c'est ce partenariat
très fort aujourd'hui qui permet à 50,2
poursuivre d'avoir cette dynamique et
cette attractivité vous l'avez dit si ça
va pas mal changé je vous propose de
voir peut-être un avant goût de ce que
ça va devenir
l'hyper centre de montigny c'est le
quartier central de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le quartier de la gare
c'est le quartier où nous avons un
centre commercial une université très
importante un très grand nombre
d'entreprises et des habitants ce
quartier il a 40 ans il s'agissait de le
faire évoluer à l'époque où il a été
conçu c'était un quartier très minéral
avec une grande priorité à la voiture
en 1985 l'immense chantier du quartier
gare se déploie pour donner la cure à
saint quentin en yvelines avec plus de
130 mille mètres carrés de commerces de
logements du bureau et d'équipements
[Musique]
désormais qu'on replace l'humain au
centre des préoccupations on replace
aussi tout ce qui touche aux espaces
verts et donc il fallait pouvoir
transformer tout cela mais emporté
l'adhésion des habitants et c'est pour
ça que ça a été une grande première sur
saint quentin nous avons fait un travail
de concertation sans précédent pour que
le projet soit celui qui était souhaitée
est porté par les habitants du
territoire
[Musique]
la venue du centre nous souhaitons
réduire la place de la voiture est
proposé à la place des espaces
piétonniers des terrasses étendu pour
les cafés et les restaurants des pistes
cyclables également parce que c'est un
enjeu fort je crois pour nous
aujourd'hui de permettre aux gens
d'accéder facilement à la gare et dans
partir facilement à vélo
[Musique]
la place de la gare avec la l'immeuble
de l'âne rouge qui va être prochainement
démolie pour que l'on voir se
reconstruire à la place des immeubles de
bureaux qui seront ouvert sur le
quartier de façon à ce que la place de
la gare deviennent visibles désormais
[Musique]
il faut aussi que nous soyons plus
attractif car nous avons beaucoup
d'entreprises de recherche et
développement sur le territoire donc il
faut pouvoir accueillir de façon
satisfaisante
toute cette population salariée qui
vient sur le territoire et ses gagnants
pour nous parce que si nous savons
attirer les jeunes ingénieurs du
territoire nous savons aussi répondre
aux besoins des jeunes du territoire
[Musique]
nous avons le plaisir de nous promener
en compagnie de thierry michel vous vous
occupez du budget de saint quentin en
yvelines là on fait une petite escale à
la gare de la verrière alors la question
de la mobilité c'est important dans les
investissements très très important
aujourd'hui on aurait bien qu un
comportement qui a changé chez les
personnes qui habitent saint quentin en
yvelines la voiture bon a toujours son
existence pourvoi que d'autres moyens de
locomotion pour lesquels les journaux
min thein le vélo on est même
des trottinettes continuer discussion
puis la marche à pied parce que
finalement c'est très intéressant donc
c'est un sujet sur lequel on travaille
énormément dans le cas du budget vous
avez évoqué le vélo
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comptabilise
420 km de pistes cyclables alors est ce
qu'on peut dire que les mobilités douces
et l'avenir l'avenir on peut me dire que
c'est le présent depuis quelques années
maintenant saint-quentin fait un effort
très important sur les pistes cyclables
mais sur d'autres où dit on peut voir
circuler des trottinettes donc c'est
vraiment l'avenir de pouvoir se dépasser
de différentes manières puis il ya la
manière qu'on n'utilise actuellement ces
deux marchés effectivement qui est très
importante donc oui dans toutes les
conceptions budgétaire maintenant c'est
un élément incontournable de la
préparation d'un budget sur l'année
voire sur plusieurs exercices l'hyper
centre et la gare de la verrière font
partie des grands projets de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et bien
d'autres et sur ce que je vais appeler
des opérations a dit récurrentes qui
sont multiples et on va pas s'y attarder
mais je crois que ce qui est important
c'est les opa sur structurantes
finalement parce que c'est ça qui montre
vraiment tout le poids de saint quentin
en yvelines dans les réalisations alors
on a plusieurs sur cet exercice 2022 pas
très loin d'ici il ya le début des
travaux pour le commissariat d'elancourt
il va y avoir des chantiers sur deux
médiathèques à elancourt et attrapes et
enfin ce sera certainement le plus gros
chantier son plan financier de
l'exercice 2022 masse et la gare de la
verrière où nous sommes présents
actuellement avec effectivement une
rénovation de la gare et du parking donc
voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur ces grosses
opérations alors justement petit focus
tout de suite sur le futur pôle gare de
la verrière une gare intermodale à
l'image de nos déplacements
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines continue d'investir notamment
sur les transports et sur les gars on
peut citer la gare de montigny mais il
ya aussi la gare de la verrière qui est
une guerre importante pour le territoire
puisque nous avons 5,7 millions de
voyageurs par an que nous avons l'accès
aux lignes n et u est finalement aussi
une desserte par treize lignes de bus
[Musique]
non aujourd'hui on a décidé
effectivement d'investir sur cette gare
à la fois pour améliorer les conditions
des voyageurs à la fois aussi pour
améliorer les circulation automobile
avec les travaux du carrefour qui aura
prochainement au niveau de la rd 13 au
niveau de la station la future station
ecobus également et puis favoriser aussi
les modes doux les mods actif je pense
aux vélos donc les travaux qui sont en
cours maintenant depuis un moment se
font en plusieurs étapes plusieurs
phases on a eu la voie d'accès à ce qui
sera le futur parking relais 900 places
pour les automobilistes et les voyageurs
qui des travaux qui ont été réalisés
notamment avec des travaux
d'accessibilité je pense notamment pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite et on
va rentrer progressivement dans une
phase de travaux maintenant importante
qui va être celle de la réalisation du
parking relais et puis de l'ensemble du
bol d'air pour favoriser l'intermodalité
c'est un projet évidemment qui est très
important puisqu'il s'inscrit aussi aux
côtés d'un projet d'aménagement urbain
celui de guerre bécane où nous aurons 80
mille mètres carrés d'activités
économiques qui a à peu près 1000
logements donc finalement c'est tout un
secteur qui va être en mutation et une
vraie volonté de l'agglomération
d'accompagner aujourd'hui
l'intermodalité et des qualités
aujourd'hui d'accès aux voyageurs des
transports en commun
e
nous sommes de retour avec thierry
michel alors j'ai une petite question
qui pourrait nous fâcher la dette dans
tout ça non non c'est pas un sujet de
fâcherie à 50 ans navy je vous le dis
tout de suite parce que depuis
maintenant 2014 la dette a baissé de
plus de 100 millions d'euros ce qui
permet d'ailleurs à 50 ans de retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre pour pouvoir
porter de gros projets dans les années à
venir d'ailleurs cette gestion de dette
elle est reconnue elle est revenue par
l' agence de notation standard and poor
ce qui tous les ans nous note et cette
note elle est conservée par l'ajustement
la gestion des dettes mais aussi par
notre gestion dans son ensemble car
aujourd'hui c'est la gestion globale de
50 ans qui a été reconnue par cette
agence de notation et les impôts qu'ils
n'ont pas augmenté malgré la baisse de
la dotation à tout à fait on a fait en
sorte de stabiliser la fiscalité parce
que bon on a un événement qui est
ponctuelle qui vit à la crise du coc
vite sur cette baisse de la cvae et on
espère bien que l'activité économique
reprenant on peut avoir des nouvelles
ressources qui nous permettront de
continuer sans avoir à toucher à la
fiscalité qu'elles cassent pas merci
beaucoup thierry michel merci johanna
merci à vous et à très bientôt pour un
prochain numéro des skis mag
[Musique]